[Music]
sever donetsk has been under fire for
weeks but it remains a ukrainian holdout
russia encircled the city days ago and
is using a familiar strategy of
submission through bombardment
like mariupol citizens are taking cover
in an industrial plant ukrainian
officials say about 800 are hiding in
the nitrogen facility along with an
unknown number of soldiers
invading forces have seized almost every
other part of luhansk in eastern ukraine
where russia is concentrating its
offensive
russia announced it destroyed a large
cache of ukrainian weapons and military
equipment in the east monday
ukrainian police in the donetsk region
recorded images of civilian buildings
hit by missiles as they were in the
community imploring people to leave
at that moment i had a feeling that the
building was made of rubber everything
was moving
russian tactics particularly in harkief
amount to war crimes according to
amnesty international many of these
strikes were
launched using
cluster munitions which are widely
banned
as well as other
indiscriminate weapons ukrainian
soldiers the report says have positioned
themselves in residential areas
violating international humanitarian
laws and drawing fire but
this
in no way justifies the relentless and
discriminated shelling of the city by
russian forces
the war over ukraine's sovereignty is
nearing its fourth month
krystal gamansen global news london